[Music]
at full speed firing its guns this tank
would be a terrifying sight on the
battlefield among old and captured
Soviet tanks the t72 is the Ukrainian
Army's
Workforce crewman say it gets the job
done but Russians know its weak points
mikyo is a company commander in a recent
battle an anti-tank guided missile cost
him equipment and
Men He says more modern machines with
better armor would save lives on and off
the
Battlefield my only wish is to destroy
the enemy and drive them out of our land
when we hear about the shelling of
Civilian areas civilian losses our
motivation goes
up the war with Russia is approaching
the 2-year Mark everyone seems to have
lost something
someone artum says he constantly worries
about the safety of soldiers under his
command many suffer concussion
from being so close to constant shelling
and bombing he says modern fighter jets
would end the war
sooner storm right now there is an
assault going on but all of the forests
are mind it's very slow dangerous
exhausting it's very difficult and this
makes this war even tougher more cruel
Jets solve such questions normal people
don't have to die equipment doesn't feel
pain it doesn't have
children Frontline fighting can be
unrelenting but they say it must end in
Victory they would not wish a war with
Russia on anyone else trench positions
like this are Ukraine's tip of the spear
for their counter offensive on the
southern front dug in on a tree line
Wide Open Spaces on either side and the
Russian positions are just a few hundred
meters away not having enough air power
to challenge Russian incursions into
Ukrainian airspace has meant the
wholesale destruction of Civilian areas
indiscriminate bombing abandoned homes
once thriving towns in
ruins more equipment and ammunition is
good but people are the most important
thing in this War equipment will help
these people finish the job and get home
faster with a year to dig in on the
southern front Russian defenses are
formidable he says recent Ukrainian
gains prompting them to throw everything
they have at military positions as well
as civilian areas desperate to stop
another breakthrough and hold the line
Zan basravi Al jazer oriv on Ukraine's
Southern
front make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer